GT right now is my favorite package for
building pretty data display tables it
offers a bunch of tools to help you get
your display tables exactly the way you
want them to look one thing I love is
the calls merge helper function it lets
you combine multiple values into a
single table column for example suppose
we have a data set with separate
variables for latitude and longitude but
we want to combine them into a
coordinates column in our display table
calls merge lets us select the columns
to merge and Define how they should look
when combined now look at the station
name and C caption variables suppose we
want to combine these two into a single
column and clean up those missing values
here we add the station caption only if
the caption
exists I don't know about you but before
GT I found myself using ters mutate
function to handle these kind of column
merging actions but that's not right you
often have to convert numeric factor or
datetime values into text and doing so
you lose information like order and
things can get weird fast these GT
helper functions help you avoid these